we were told today
there was supposed to be some militia
that was going to storm
into dc and that they needed 5 000
national guard troops to protect the
capital because
these militia conspiracy individuals
believe that march
4th was the true inauguration day
apparently they believe that the united
states is a corporation and that this
corporation started with a 20th
amendment
and it's just it's nonsensical however
there has been a lot of talk about
something called strass how generational
theory
and talk that we're entering the fourth
turning
which basically predicts societal
collapse followed by
at least according to business insider a
new world order
whatever that means so we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna riff on this stuff
there obviously there was no militia
storming dc but yet
they're still saying we need national
guard to remain for two more months
something weird is happening and i think
it's safe to say we are definitely in
some kind of crisis period
which may be i think it's this would be
the fourth turning i guess
yeah that would be the winter period the
winter period we'll talk about that but
we are joined today
by i guess a filmmaker and you've done a
ton of research and to say dmt
uh ben stewart yeah ben joseph stewart
um benjoffstewart.com
filmmaker started off as a musician that
didn't do so well so
i decided to do the uh do some tnt do
some dmt and start making films and uh
here i am i just sneezed and showed up
here i got lost and i figured oh wow
some guy like pulled up on my parking
lot and we were like
you know ian walked out and said hey you
ever tried dmt and he was like actually
and we're like come on in
got it i'm actually in the fifth
dimension right now yes
let's talk about the fourth turning i
will say i saw your band hyrule sonic
play and it was incredible
so don't give up that was back in the
chat yeah yeah that was hot
yeah you're really really good i maybe
you didn't know the right marketing at
the time but i'd like to
like to see you play again it was
interesting man that was uh
11 years we were together and we we
started like a year after we started
we're on lollapalooza with
wow this is jane's addiction audio slave
a perfect circle
um sounds like you were actually pretty
successful with that
yeah you by the the bands that we played
with you would imagine and then you'd
look at our bank account and be like oh
you poor thing
[Laughter]
we were touring non-stop and we did some
really excellent shows but um
it was just it was just a strange time
and in the middle of it i started
deciding to make films because people
really liked the lyrics and they were
like what's the message about i was
going to make a 15-minute film
about the message of the band and it
turned into a two-hour documentary that
had nothing to do with the band
it was called esoteric agenda i just put
it up online for free
and um and people then asked for more so
i
began doing that and then eventually
what kind of turned it into a career was
gaia.com
they hand selected me to they brought me
in to do a whole series on psychedelics
so all this crazy dmt stuff now we're
going to talk about
it it all does kind of come together i
guess you know we normally like to do
like here's some big news of the day
here's some cultural issue
but i think you know we're gonna have
like a bigger picture conversation about
where this might all be going
generational theory but then there's
also the the
this is really interesting stuff the the
studies into dmt the extended state dmt
stuff
where they're putting people on you
mentioned this earlier putting people on
dmt
drips so we'll get in all that stuff but
we're definitely going to talk about
like the political space and where we're
all headed
uh don't forget we also got sour patch
let's present them right here in the
corner pushing all the buttons i'm
stoked for this conversation so we'll
see how this goes yeah this should get
this
this should get weird and trippy yes
we'll do more of these episodes
uh but before we do head over to
timcast.com and become a member because
we got a ton
of members only exclusive episodes and
segments
we got one just the other day jack
murphy says progressives can't be alpha
and
he says marxism is objectively
anti-masculine and it's a really
interesting conversation
and we also have a bonus episode with
cassandra fairbanks ryan long we got
full episodes of james o'keefe
check it out we set this up because we
might get banned in this great purge
that's happening you may have heard that
right side broadcasting network they got
suspended for
simply filming donald trump speaking
while the speech had fake news they said
false information so they straight up
i think the suspension is two weeks they
are taking out news organizations
rsbn did not put on an opinion so things
are getting absolutely crazy i mean it
was a wild and crazy day for censorship
today
a lot of people think dr seuss stuff is
silly but they're now ebay's banning
people from even selling their existing
dr seuss books
so we are definitely in some kind of
crisis but yeah like if you own a dr
seuss book and you're like i'm going to
sell it to ian
and i put it up on ebay you want to buy
it they're saying no it's hate speech
it's offensive you can't have it they're
going to
drive the price of those way up they're
already up like 20 grand wow it's crazy
so now you got to go like hunt people
down and try and get one like find them
and like
go on yeah black market quests but this
is a really good example of how insane
everything is getting
and so definitely go to timecast.com
become a member let me start by showing
you this
article and i do this uh with with these
articles specifically because
i want to make sure everybody realizes
we're not just pulling these things
you know out of thin air these are
conversations that actually happen these
are articles that actually exist and
these are ideas that we did not come up
with
business insider says a book published
nearly 25 years ago predicted america
would hit a great crisis
climaxing around 2020 and then up next
is a millennial versus boomer standoff
that will
usher in a new world order they say
america sees a turning
every 20 years as one generation
displaces another
and the dynamic between one particular
generation entering elderhood
and another entering young adulthood
creates a crisis every 80 years
according to a theory prophesied in neil
howe and william strasse's the fourth
turning
the authors wrote the next crisis era
would start around 2005
and climax around 2020 and would involve
millennials and boomers fighting over
the shape of the world to come
there are some similarities between
recent events and the book's predictions
the 2008 financial crisis can be seen as
the catalyst they mentioned
and in 2020 in early 2021 unrest has
shaken the economy
politics it says the economy twice and
the economy okay
it's unclear whether the fourth turning
is how and stross characterize it is
really happening right now
but the parallels are certainly
eye-catching there's also some other
uh there's other other theories there's
also thucydides trap
which suggests that whenever an economic
power is about to displace the principal
superpower
war breaks out in the past 16 major
instances
12 times there has been very serious war
many fear that we are now entering this
period with china
i guess the bigger question is if these
academics predicted this
was going to be the fourth turning and
we are going to enter in some
catastrophic period
if people can see thucydides trap are
there efforts to prevent it
and before we open it go into like the
bigger discussion i'll just point out
uh they say that the last 80-year period
start
and i guess it started just after world
war ii right
actually why don't you explain like what
this means well the whole thing
you know so the fourth turning is the
fourth season that's the winter
crisis and you know so they call it a
ceculum which means a long life
um this goes actually all the back to
the etruscan
prior to the romans but it starts let's
just say it starts in the
spring with a high and then it goes into
an awakening
which would be the summer and then the
fall is called the unraveling and then
the winter
is the crisis period and it keeps
turning i heard a really good guy
actually interviewing
um neil howe i think it was and he said
like you know if history
doesn't repeat it surely rhymes because
every single time these crisis periods
come back around
they're not exactly the same but they
resemble each other and there's there's
core
tenets to them that resemble one another
and um
and yeah they surely said like the the
book came out in 97
they said somewhere around 2005 give or
take a couple years
there's going to be an inciting incident
and if it comes later it'll probably
come at around 2008
right when two-thirds of the boomer
generation i think it was would
be eligible for their social security so
that was the housing
collapse right there and that would be
an economic inciting incident that would
lead into
and i wrote some things down we can get
to it later but they
in chapter six of the book the fourth
turning there's eerie
like very eerie kinds of predictions
that go right into
what you could call now the winter
period the crisis period and then game
of thrones they were like winter is
coming
yeah long winter but about but does that
mean we're through the worst of it we're
we're on our way out towards this
you know beautiful utopian springtime
it's very interesting because like they
in the book they said
it will it won't be any shorter than 15
years it won't be any longer than 20
years if
history repeats in the same way it's
never gone any longer than 20 years
so after because i think neil howe works
in dc
now and he advises people and he said
somewhere around 2028
it should be concluded and that's when
the high the next high will start
and if you think about it like the the
crisis is like a crunching period and
anytime you
come out of a crunch it feels like a
high there's a big restructuring
so i've heard 2025 is the year to look
at
so then when did the for the last spring
time start
last spring time would have been man
um 1945 after 1945 i mean that that
seems like a pretty definitive end
to the crisis period that means the
crisis period
reached its end with mass bloodshed and
76 million dead
when yeah yeah when was the new deal
because apparently that was
they also mentioned that in the book the
new deal because they
they don't just talk about like war but
for some reason when you go back
80 to 90 years you look at world war ii
great depression 80 to 90 years before
that
give or take some civil war before that
the the last winter was the revolution
before that because they're talking
mainly anglo-saxon history
uh the glorious revolution in england
and so it it
lines up when you look at it definitely
lines up there's other authors who
popped onto
1933 new deal yeah okay and the glorious
revolution england was like when they
made prince or king john
sign the magna carta is that what that
was was that
it was sometime in the 1600s i think oh
that was 1200
okay never mind yeah four turnings
before yeah yeah
um i i've noticed that in 2028 this year
you're saying might be
the new awake or not the awakening but
the uh the high the high
is when graphene is purported to become
peak which means that society has
completely
in in inundated itself with graphene
like we're
instead of using steel we're now using
graphene for buildings touch screens
battery power
electricity all that interesting yeah
there's a lot of predictions elon musk
says 2023
we should be able to expect um super
intelligent ai
i mean these are all you know
speculations do you want me to just read
just like two paragraphs of what they
predicted would happen in this
period yeah okay so they said around
2005
a financial event will likely spark the
the coming crisis
a succession will be spoken of or
succession will be spoken of heavily
secession i'm sorry secession like
seceding
states succeeding in the union say and
they said it could be something having
to do with like taxes and irs
what was it they said that was going to
happen in 2005 no no
they said starting starting in 2005 so
they're saying there will be a financial
event is usually what sparks these
things
and then after that they're talking
about during the entire crisis period
you'll
see these things come up so secession
will be spoken of heavily
a potential terrorist group may blow up
an aircraft and claim to have portable
weapons of mass destruction or nuclear
weapons
the u.s will potentially strike
the responsible country preemptively i
don't know what that means because the
you know they they already attacked they
already attacked um
some will blame the president for con
concocting the attack for political
purposes
militia groups will rise up against um
urban gangs
uh cyber attacks cdc may announce the
spread of a new communicable
uh virus this is all in chapter six wow
i'm not making this up what is happening
you know uh a new communicable virus
that will reach densely pop
populated areas and kill some i'm trying
to use as many verbatim words as i can
mandatory quarantine will happen
president
uh will order national guard into major
cities
again urban gangs battling suburban
militias
and calls mount for the president to
declare martial law
insurrection um will
i i know they said that uh several times
in chapter six i just didn't get the
exact
sentence but they mention insurrection
several times and
all events will escalate they're like
every
the inciting incident will set off a
chain reaction of other events
and until the climax there will be
nothing that brings down the intensity
like world war ii when world war ii
officially ended boom
springtime next so that means 2027
is going to be brutal going to be
absolutely chaos
i mean the theory is maybe it was 911
that sparked this
and that was the the aircraft thing that
they actually mentioned
this is the brutal ending too oh and
they wrote they wrote this when in 1997.
it was published in 97 which means i
think they started writing it in 88 with
a different idea
so wait wait wait wait they wrote and
they published it way before
9 11 and said some will get an aircraft
that's crazy
yeah they they also mentioned and this
is just in the book
i did a podcast on kyle kingsbury um not
too long ago and he
i turned him onto the book and then he
hit me up i didn't even hear this part
he was like
in the very first chapter they mentioned
bill gates
eugenics and popul uh depopulation in
the same sentence
in in 97 yeah and and
or in the same paragraph there's one of
those two and i didn't even catch that
and then they
so they mention him a lot they mention
al gore a lot um
and so they they also give like what you
would call
a constellation like people born under
certain like
we would all be millennials i imagine
and so we're born during the unraveling
and we've only known unraveling in
crisis
i think i think he might be a it's
called like xenial
yeah generation y i was told growing up
no generation
not quite x like the tail end of
generation x okay 79
was the year yeah so that was that would
be till there was no crisis when i was a
kid it was beautiful roses it was
awesome
so you would be considered a nomad and i
would be we'd be considered
heroes people uh i'm 38. so i was like
right at the beginning of it
and then uh people born in a crisis
period
period are called artists and then
people born during a high are called
prophets
and so they they go into a lot of detail
as to why they're named that
and and so they talk about the boomers
their role in this crisis
generation x in this crisis so they they
predicted
insurrection they predicted militias
portable weapons a lot of this stuff
you know i will say we'd have to go into
the book and
i'll tell you this i didn't read the
book maybe they say here's a hundred
things that we think will happen and
then you just cherry-pick the seven
that are relevant to us go ah that
proves i'm right not really
so is it just like they threw a bunch of
darts at the wall and said we'll see
what happens and then
we're cherry-picking i'll tell you
exactly what it is because this
i was listening to it this morning
everything i said
i didn't really leave out anything if i
might have left out anything it would
have been one thing um and this is all
in like two paragraphs and so they
what they said was right afterwards they
were like likely none of these things
will actually happen
in this way but the underlying tone
will things like this will happen this
will be the nature of things to happen
and so there wasn't much other than this
this was like two paragraphs
i just distilled it down right right
right you know so
they and then they went on to say like
in a crisis period if it
if tensions keep rising and there is any
spark of violence
it will likely lead to war so i'm i'm
trying to use their words as much as
possible if it does lead to war
it's likely to end in total war the
the enemy rendered nil um and
afterwards once society dies a new one
is born
and basically there's there's no way to
stop
a winter period from coming but do they
think that the united states
is going to enter a new spring or in
that context what if china crushes the
united states and destroys our society
in that sense what they would say
because they they do say it is possible
for
the united states to be the the loser in
this and they're really
talking mainly eccentric around the u.s
so when they do talk about this um they
say that no matter what the spring is
also coming
so spring will definitely come but
that's not really saying much for the
the losing side you know what's crazy
is that you go back 80 years what do you
got the end of world war ii
you go back 80 years before that what do
you got in the civil war
you go back 80 years before that what do
you got the revolution end of the
revolution these are all wars
crazy and what they say is every single
time if there's war
the most um powerful weapons of war
are definitely used there's there's no
way around it so you look back
you know the the um atomic bomb at the
end of world war
ii before that what was the most
powerful thing the gatling gun no the
gatling gun i think was
1873 maybe okay my gun history good no
probably not
but uh they were using percussion
revolvers
i think they were man i don't know a lot
about guns but i'm sure a lot of people
are like i'm surprised you know those
things existed
uh they had these uh i'm pretty sure
they had percussion revolvers basically
you would load the charge like you know
what is it called muzzle load
but it's like you you pour into the side
of the revolver and then you use a
percussion cap
on the back and then there were a couple
different models
uh really amazing technology for the
time i i'd say there was one
where had two triggers you pull one to
to rotate and pull the hammer and the
other to fire the hammer
and uh they're not particularly
convenient but it was like
it was uh i think it was the london
armory was it london arms company i
don't know a whole lot about this stuff
i should learn my gun history
and uh they were selling to the
confederate i think they were selling
the confederates
and so they're giving them these
percussion rifles so that was like
really revolutionary tech at the time
that you could carry around this loaded
you know i think they had what eight
shots maybe
and so coming from the muzzle loaded era
of just like you know
stuffing the ball and you know through
the muzzle and then firing and then
doing again
all of a sudden these guys had small
arms where they could go boom boom boom
so that's that was legitimate technology
so what do you think it is today
is it even i don't weaponry like
explosives that's this so this is what
i've been talking about when it comes to
this concept of like civil war and all
that
is no it's it's it's mind control it is
absolute mind control
when when uh the easiest way to to
understand that we are all being mind
control
mind control is first when people inv
okay let me let me tell you something i
talked to people about persuasion
techniques i used to do non-profit
fundraising
literally walking up to strangers on the
street and being like i need you to give
me 100
right now and i could make people sign
over credit cards it's really amazing
when you consider there's a job
where someone's standing in the street
greets a stranger
and then says give me your credit card
information right now and you will get
nothing in return that is the
fundraiser's job when they do the street
canvassing
what you're doing is you're selling them
an idea so it takes real persuasion and
skills i always tell people you are not
invincible
no one is everyone can be controlled and
manipulated
and you know what everyone says not me
so here's what i do whenever i explain
to people i'll say i can make you say
something
and they'll say no you can't i can make
you say something you don't even realize
it i can make you say
yeah but not me want to bet and they'll
be like what i'm not i won't say that
and then i'll wait a minute or two and
then i'll be like let me explain to you
how how mind control manipulation works
i'll break down the basics of it and
they'll go yeah but
not me and i'll go you owe me 10 bucks i
made you say that i knew it's not so
much that i made you but i knew the
sequence of events to get you to say it
considering that i always tell people if
mind control
mental manipulation wasn't a thing
coca-cola would not be spending billions
of dollars on these commercials and
billboards and research
you would not have social media
companies selling your data to predict
your behavior
they want to know what makes you do
things and why so they can exploit you
for resources
it sounds a bit nefarious you can break
it down to the guy at coke wants to make
10 more dollars
and he's going to do whatever he can to
figure out how to get you to buy another
coke
it's called marketing but now you have
this era
where it's been so incredibly refined
that big tech companies they know what
what you think they know why you're
thinking it they know what they want you
to think and they are absolutely
stripping away the individuality
through these networks what's happening
now is whether intentionally or not
we cannot go outside in big cities for
the most part
mostly in blue areas can't go to bars
can't go to restaurants gotta wear a
mask
hard to talk when you're wearing a mask
hard to read someone's lips a lot of
people don't realize this but when we
talk to each other we are reading lips
so there's a bunch of research showing
how you can change the sound
but the lips will still make people hear
a different word when you're in a bar
and someone's talking
you will hear the sound and the
movements of their mouth and go i know
what they're saying
take away the ima you know take away the
ability to see their mouth and now
you're going to be more confused
very very difficult to communicate ideas
during this lockdown
then you go on social media and they say
you can't talk about this this this this
or this
you can't say that donald trump's speech
gone outright right side broadcasting
network you're banned for two weeks for
even showing the president saying it
ideas are being restricted this is the
greatest weapon
we've ever seen imagine if in during the
civil war
a guy showed up to the confederate and
said i will win you this war without you
firing a single shot
will you buy this weapon and say what is
it and they would say the printing press
or the ability to spread propaganda in a
guaranteed manner
what if i told you that the people of
the north could only
read what we made them read we could
we could tell them that we could have
them vote for for insane things that
would destroy their own country
we can have them vote for sending you
know for politicians that would harm
them
we can trick them into believing they're
so that our soldiers are in different
areas
you control what they think and you need
not fire a single shot you could march
into dc
and never have to fight anyone and they
will smile and celebrate as you do it
that's what's happening with big tech
and all this manipulation
who needs a nuclear bomb what's that
going to do scare and harm people
in today's day and age why bother
forcing someone
through violence when you can simply
tell them to do it and they will if you
look at the ccp
what they're doing to the uyghurs like
that's violent like why not be violent
if you can
as i guess that's up to these
psychopaths is what they're thinking and
i've listened to putin talk about
weapons of war
and said that all this defense against
intercontinental ballistic missiles has
become null now you can fire
late like orbital strike from and he was
very vague about what kind of weapons
from god yeah he was like they can't
stop it because the united states can't
stop
you guys know what rods you know rods
from god are i heard about
tungsten hypothetical tungsten rods
floating in orbit that they just release
and then gravity pulls it down and
interesting i didn't know it was that
yep i thought it had more to do with
satellites but
um well yeah satellite would be holding
a tungsten rod and just released okay
and then at least
i'm also concerned with drone dogs like
we were talking about drone dogs before
like
drone weapons you know like nuclear mis
nuclear bombs attached to a drone
let's get into that but i i do want to
talk a little bit more about strass how
and then i do want to talk about the
police state
the the the the cyber dogs they got in
new york
uh so this this the stras howe
generational theory
when does it start is that was there
something before the revolutionary war
or are they just basically saying hey we
had a revolution
80 years later civil war eighty years
eight years later world war ii probably
another thing is going to happen
or they or was there something we just
don't talk about before that
yeah you know so in the book they're not
really clear the earliest
uh crisis period that i think they
mentioned is the glorious revolution
though they do go back into roman
history and they say that the term
sacrum means a long life because by the
way
you know anyone who's entering this
crisis period um
wasn't around in the last crisis so uh
it's usually people
are dead they're they're not around
enough to even know what the pattern
means so history repeating itself
they don't quite get it but it goes back
to the glorious revolution
like i said in um in england before that
they don't really get
much into this period so it seems like
they're talking anglo-saxon american
history but
they do mention and this is where my
understanding breaks down is
other countries going through their own
cycles and they said
if two countries this was also part of
chapter six if anyone wants to go in
there and check it out of the fourth
turning
if two countries reach their crisis
period at the same exact time
usually that's when it uh it
will definitely end in war or it's a lot
more likely to end in war if two periods
are
two major powers specifically are in
crisis at the same time
but it seems like well we're facing two
potential threats china
but also civil war and so if you're if
we look internally
we have two tribal factions you have the
populist right and then you have the
establishment the populist left
tends to support the establishment tends
to well they'll rag on joe biden but
they'll throw their weight behind him so
you know you may as well have that then
you have disaffected moderate
individuals like me
i throw my weight behind trump for
instance to a certain degree voted for
the guy
supported him in some endeavors but i
i'm fairly critical just like the
populist after critical the democrats
but
also throw their weight behind them it
seems like because of
facebook's dominance twitter the
internal war being fought right now does
include
low-tier violence and mass protests and
riots as well as
many you know these individuals who
stormed the capital so there is violence
but it seems like the bigger fight is
just the fact that lines of
communication are completely controlled
right now by
the left tribe which would say to me
that by 2028
the the populist right tribe will be
non-existent if that's the end
of the of the you know major climax if
they're talking about insurrection
and violence and talk of secession it
sounds like
we are entering another civil war period
texas is already they got they got
legislation
pushed forward that will allow the state
to vote for secession
and the texas gop is supporting the bill
i support the idea that people should be
allowed to vote for things they want
will they actually be able to pull it
off i don't know but if joe biden
is pushing this very very heavy gun
control stuff
that's the easiest way to look at how
joe biden's policy demands
do not fly at all with red states
and and some blue states to a certain
degree what i mean by this is
the gun control measures he proposed he
proposes are very good
for blue cities the people who live
there they want them
they like them they don't want guns and
they live in really close proximity with
cops everywhere so for them they get it
but joe biden wants to have this gun
control even in red states nationwide
so what's happening now is the
ideological divide between how someone
wants to live is so
they're so diametrically opposed that
when joe biden is like i'm gonna pass
laws that benefit cities
you know to help with everybody else you
end up with
talk of right now we have many counties
who want to secede from those states to
go to red states
but sooner or later we're going to see
more than just murmurs
we're in 2021 if the climax is supposed
to be
or we're in the climax but if the end is
supposed to be 2028
i don't think it's fair to call the
climax right now because if this is
going to keep escalating until
it finally goes off the cliff and just
stops and then restarts then the climax
is going to be 2027 december 31st i'll
tell you i think september 11th was the
inciting incident and we're in year 20
right now
i don't know about airplanes i mean the
financial crisis was was way
way way worse now we can talk in terms
of
uh global damage and societal change
the echo the economic collapse it
sparked occupy wall street
it created years of mass protests it led
to the rise of people like trump and
bernie sanders
so the reason we get someone like trump
a lot of the people who supported trump
were occupy supporters
now i get it 9 11 was always was a
nightmarish tragedy
and the patriot act which is basically
the martial law part of this
yeah but the patriot act was if if
anything
people didn't care they didn't care sure
some activists cared but for the most
part it didn't impact regular people
the mortgage-backed security crisis the
financial crisis having that followed
brought people to zero and people were
were
desperate they were angry and what did
they see the banks get bailed out
so what happens then as you go to occupy
wall street you had left and right
basically screaming at the establishment
well try as they might and they
succeeded they kept the left and the
right divided on this issue
when the young leftists came in to
zuccotti park they drove away the
libertarian the conservative ideas that
were there
and dominated with far left populist
ideas you then move forward and you have
the rise of bernie sanders
the establishment clearly did not want
bernie sanders to have any power
but they were they seem to have been
taken by surprise
at the rise of this left populist
movement and hillary was furious
and bernie was rivaling her she was
supposed to win bernie was supposed to
get close they cheated
they were submitting for you know one
example is they gave the questions to
hillary so she would know
what they were going to ask her and
could prepare beforehand the whole thing
seemed to be dirty
and bernie sanders supporters believed
it but you also got many people who saw
the populist message from trump
the interesting thing about the
2015-2016 presidential cycle
was that bernie sanders and donald trump
had many of the same core policies
bernie sanders is on record speaking
with vox.com saying open borders is a
koch brothers right wing proposal
you had people i met i met three guys in
anaheim at a trump rally who said
they were originally bernie sanders
supporters they flipped for trump when
hillary won why
they said bernie sanders is a guy whose
job has been has been to be a politician
and he's talking about these free trade
agreements he's talking about union
workers i like these ideas
he's a little too far left for me but he
seems genuine and way better than the
establishment
when hillary clinton basically took it
from bernie they said
well the only other guy talking about
these free trade agreements and bringing
our jobs back is trump
so they flip for trump two different
elements of the populist revolt
which started primarily because of the
economic collapse
and how it destroyed the lives of many
people now you have two things to
consider for one boomers lives were
destroyed and they got angry
so they said bernie or trump you then
had millennials who are now entering a
job market
competing with boomers for entry level
jobs now you have gen z
who literally entered the market after
that where there were no jobs
and so they're all basically becoming
socialists or i should say
they're very socialistic albeit there is
a slight
uh uh push towards some conservatism but
it's no surprise
that you see so many socialist youth
when they're like
by the time i was old enough to get a
job what scraps were left were taken up
by millennials the millennials are like
i did everything i was told to
and then when i tried to get a job all i
could go was entry-level garbage i could
barely pass my student loans
the system isn't working when you take a
look at the m1 money stock what do you
see
up until 2008 there's a slow and steady
increase
at 2008 it sharply increases and then
here
in 2021 i'm sorry in 2020 it shoots
straight up
now they say it's because they change
the reporting metric for it
however before they change the reporting
metric the spike had
already begun so if anything it seems
like they changed the reporting metric
because they needed to mask it to some
capacity
so in my view 2008 was this major
economic catalyst which sparked this
populist uprising
which leads to donald trump which leads
to now claims of democrats saying
insurrection the culture war and the
clashes and everything around it are all
merging into one
and it's coming to a point where we just
had federal charges for antifa dropped
in portland
yet they're going after some befuddled
granny who walked into the capital
building when the cops opened the door
for her
republicans and people in the tribal
right can see that there's a double
standard and they're being treated like
second-class citizens
that antifa for over a year can burn
down entire cities
and the vice president before now at the
vice president
literally can fundraise on their behalf
and it is accepted
but you get a video of the cops opening
the door at the capitol and saying
well i don't agree with it but i think i
agree with you right to protest and
welcoming them all in
and these people walking smiling taking
selfies respecting the velvet ropes
smiling and taking pictures with cops
and now these people are facing serious
charges and they're being called
insurrectionists
and lawyers won't even represent them
now we're seeing the wave of censorship
that's escalating
the conflict has only gotten worse both
sides are ready to just slam into each
other and i think
it's going to get bad i think the the
2008 thing
makes a little bit more sense mainly
because there's something about the
the winter crisis period that they
mentioned
so like instead of just looking at the
external like what are what are the
events and
things like that take a look at people's
behavior because they they do say
sparks inciting events if it happens
in a different turning like in the in
the spring or the summer or the fall
we behave differently and so in 2001
you didn't see as many people amassing
so they say in a high
period which is right after a crisis the
number one thing that sparks uh
create a synergy it's actually synergy
um
in an awakening which you go back and
look at the hippie generation it's
argument that's the number one thing
sparks uh do
and then during an unraveling it's
anxiety but during
a winter period it's action and you see
a lot more action come the 2008 like you
know
from that entering to um
uh the occupy and then everything from
there people and
and even just the ease of social media
getting together
bringing your ideas together it seems
like people are a lot more action
oriented
and they do say that you know the new
presidents that come in during this
period
will will have a you know no bs like
straight to the point
let's get down to business kind of like
action orientation
the one thing they do say which i
noticed because i was listening to a
bunch of podcasts
um on january 6th when the thing
happened at the capitol
and they were in this book they say that
these events are going to start
devaluing
um like basically there's going to be a
massive devaluation
and i remember that thing that happened
on the sixth the the storming of the
capital
it didn't really reflect itself in the
market the same way bitcoin kind of
stayed the same
everything else kind of stayed the same
stocks were going up i remember a lot of
people
that i was listening to and these were
just people who are like you know
speculating constantly and they have
their podcast and they're saying
something is is not right something is
disconnected here from reality
so that is one thing that the book like
it was it was
suspecting that during this period
you're gonna see um devaluation
constantly
maybe it's happening and we're not
seeing it oh no no it is happening
there are reports that the cost of food
is already starting to skyrocket going
up double-digit percentages
uh fast food and dining it's just it's
way up
so there's major predictions of food
shortages
and or food inflation so texas had a
food shortage because of the winter
storm it made it impossible for trucks
to come in
but now one of the things one of the
things i'm seeing a lot of people don't
notice this stuff
because we're basically frogs in a pot
we're coming to a slow boil we don't
realize it
i i saw someone on twitter say i went to
the grocery store to buy a week's worth
of groceries and i couldn't believe it
was almost double what i normally spend
a lot of people aren't really paying
attention to how much it's costing them
and
there's a couple reasons for it for one
frogs in a pot you don't really notice
these gradual changes
but a lot of people just don't have
money anyway you're we're not getting
the stimulus a lot of people are out of
work they're on unemployment so they're
like i don't know
not paying my rent they're not really
focusing the cost of goods right now but
they are definitely going up
the stock market is a strange disconnect
but maybe it's just because it's a
delayed reaction yeah it seems like it's
16 months behind
with bitcoin going up to 50 was it 56
000 for bitcoin before it dipped again
before i dipped again
that says something it went for in only
a few months
it went from 13 000 november to what uh
february 56
000 and only a few months it skyrocketed
that much
that says something about the confidence
of of the stock market and this country
and i have to wonder if we are just like
you mentioned six to eight months
delayed
before the market takes a hard nosedive
you know you basically convinced me that
it was 2008 is it because
the when the sparks flew of september
11th it was anxiety
and that if that's a fall if that's yeah
then that's
anxiety yeah and that's kind of the the
part of the constellation you really
have to look at
our our be and we preemptively strike
you know
we we preemptively went after a nation
or whatever but they predicted
they predicted that in the crisis or do
they predict that at some point all of
that was during the crisis that i
mentioned so that was a little early
the the preemptive strike against
another company
and and you gotta wonder i mean in the
same thing is like you know when you are
exiting
um the real fall going into the real
winter
one starts to look like the other by the
end of fall and the beginning of winter
it does just kind of fade into one
another so this
still could make sense in that respect
but i mean like there's
this was just the inciting incident and
then so like there's a lot of ways of
looking at like what are the sequence of
events
and where does it culminate like where
does it go i think
when it comes to predictions it's very
difficult
depending on your ability to calculate
the variables in front of you you can
make better and better predictions
it sounds like these guys are very very
smart
and they were able to see a wide range
of variables
and track which they thought was the
highest probability based on the things
that were going to happen in their time
period and based on history
in which case they were able to for i
would say fairly accurately predict
things
we don't expect people to be actual
psychics who can tell you on this date
at this time the lottery number will
be this but someone for someone to say
there will be an economic catalyst there
will be
insurrection and militias there will be
fights in the streets and it's like all
that stuff is happening
now the other thing i think people
should understand too is is
semantics and and the language they use
is it fair to say when they mention
the malicious fighting would it be fair
to say well we've seen
right and left clashes over the past
four or five years
in suburbs and and you know outlying
areas yeah we've seen proud boys in
antifa we've seen right wing groups
putting on shields and helmets and bats
and going and fighting the left and
we've seen the culmination of
a left-wing guy walking up to a right
wing and just putting two bolts in his
chest
is that basically what they're talking
about my opinion is it's fair to say
yes it's it's definitely fair to say
because again you look at the people
like were there protests in previous
seasons
yes like what does the action look like
here
it's it's you know tensions got a lot
higher here
and then i mean you can also go into um
it's kind of interesting because when
you mention that i
i often hear the same trigger words like
why are we hearing the word insurrection
secession um you know obviously the cdc
the spread of a new communicable disease
that blew my mind when i heard that part
of it but then even going to people like
catherine austin fitz and
you could say what you think about her
theories but she was saying you know
when she researched
the 37 protests that happened in 2020
34 of them happened within a very short
mileage around central well federal
reserve banks
and that a lot of infrastructure was
destroyed around that her theory
um was that it was to basically buy that
infrastructure for pennies on the dollar
build up the smart grid because my big
question is here is like where are we
heading
how can we visualize the spring
what is it going to look like because if
it also changes i mean most people
they're just like war is there going to
be war that's what they're afraid of
but it's also like how's the economy
going to change
everything is already moving towards
blockchain it's moving more digital
a lot more we're a lot more reliant on
the technology
um i think in africa the first baby
was you know unborn child was already
put on the blockchain
and like the moving in this direction
and i've heard the
the the big change the great reset
moving from shareholder capitalism to
stakeholder capitalism
which is you know basically it's just a
restructuring of what our economy is now
and i just find it very interesting it's
definitely going more digital
i think a bitcoin is going to be worth a
million bucks and it's going to be worth
a million bucks relatively soon well
by relative i mean within a few years i
think one bitcoin be a million dollars
it's gonna be 75k
really fast if you look at the charts
how it shot up to like 38 back down to
27
up to 56 back down to 45. it's going up
to 75. back down to 62.
while while you can look at bitcoin and
predict to a certain degree you can like
actually create you know like
here's what it did here's what it'll
likely do i think the reason we saw this
massive jump
was very different than the previous
what we saw previously with bitcoin was
i just popular uh mentions people
started talking about bitcoin as they
were buying it made the price go up then
more people talk about it and then it
created a snowball rolling down a hill
where everyone's like bitcoin's so high
and everyone's buying it
i think bitcoin skyrocketed this time
because you have
chaos uncertainty destabilization
capital insurrection donald trump's
claims of fraud all of this stuff
massive inflation
and mass inflation from the previous
year so now you're looking at and you
know
insurance companies foreign countries
now now there's rumors that twitter may
buy up a large portion of bitcoin i
think that's proven not true because
they did that apparently to buy title i
guess
but a lot of people are speculating
who's going to be the next big company
to put their balance sheet in bitcoin
because it's a safer bet than dollars
right now
tesla tesla definitely moved the needle
a bit there's this thing i'm trying to
think of the name
it was um facebook i believe
it has it's not a i don't even think
it's a crypto but it's it's
a different kind of asset that is based
upon the average
of all currencies everywhere so it's not
mainly based in one
and that's a protection protectionary
thing where like if
the dollar all of a sudden fails but
everything else stays stable
then you don't feel it that much was
that the libra token the library that's
what it is
yeah they they started it and then the
sec hit them pretty hard and they said
it was a security so they pulled back on
the program i don't know much more
interesting
yeah i didn't look too much deeper into
that either but i started seeing in this
period
a lot of people are looking forward to
the high and they're wondering like
what's stable and what has endurance
what's gonna last like is bitcoin always
going to be the gold standard for crypto
you know i i hear this talk a lot you
know i think so
first in best address i don't see why
not yeah yeah
i guess my my question is how bad will
things get
and uh you know look i have to talk
about fifth generational civil war
information warfare manipulation what do
you think
do you think you think we're in like a
civil war period uh so i've often
thought like when they said
the the weapons of war will constantly
be the most powerful and effective
weapons of war and this time around
i wonder if it's it's it doesn't seem
like explosions i think you're right it
has to do with
the colonization of the mind um i mean
you could go all the way back to the um
was it the cia director william casey
in the 80s that said like our
disinformation program will be complete
when everything the american public
believes is false i mean that's a meme
i've found that also in several books
you know i like there's also william
colby beforehand which was basically
saying yeah we definitely have
you know um we've infiltrated journalism
we have to because we have to control
the narrative
in many ways so the narrative is huge
like if you get people following the
narrative what
was it aldous huxley who said eventually
when when you have people knowing that
they're being oppressed
they revolt but if you can give them
enough bread and circuses
or just bring them their their
pharmaceutical revolution
right then how do you get people to be
quite happy in their servitude
so basically accepting the way things
that are going well
i would imagine you have to control the
narrative so then i started taking a
look at like well what's happening
today social media is so much easier for
everyone in this room is going to have a
different feed
we're going to have something different
showing up on my feed than your feed
and all of that is is part of our
digital twinning
right we all have a digital avatar
potentially run through different
simulations to see
how you know how is ben joseph stewart
with all his data going to behave if he
gets these
this kind of media you know it's i think
you know we've heard enough of that even
elon musk saying ai
writing blogs and just like if something
doesn't hit just
slightly adjust slightly adjust slightly
adjust i think it's information for sure
think about what this means you're going
to have we already have this where
ai writes news articles so this has been
around for quite some time actually
maybe over 10 years
i went to a presentation in chicago at
the
i believe it was the art institute where
some guy showed us examples
of how the ai does it at the time it was
fairly rudimentary it was like
if you have a weather system where the
data is
you know very easily you know inputted
it says thunderstorm wednesday 9 pm rain
then all they need to do is add very
simple english on
wednesday at 9 00 pm there will be a
thunderstorm and so you ended up with
this very short article that said
your weather for the week on tuesday you
can expect to see
and so it adds these very simple bits of
english and then just inputs that data
then we started seeing that around uh
sports games
because the data from sports games was
very easy they could actually write more
substantive articles
where it would say things like football
player you know
x scored you know this many points
in the game and so a quote from a guy
says this
and no one has to actually write
anything the data points just exist
from the existing you know
infrastructure like
when when when you go to google you can
see this the score from like a football
mat a
football game or something all that has
to do is take all of those things
find the name find the players you know
stats for the game and then
boom you've got a substantive article
now we're coming to this point where
why do we need woke rage bait writers
when an ai
can you you can enter in a subject
matter you could simply just type in
okay we have a guy and he's racist
he was in texas he yelled at
a waiter and then it can generate
automatically the opinion
and if it doesn't work then the next
time it can learn what the better
opinion is that will get more people to
click it
we're getting dangerously close to this
point where you're not going to realize
the
the opinion you're reading isn't from a
human being it's automatically generated
by an ai who doesn't know or care
because it doesn't have the
capacity to and it's making you lose
your mind and want to go insane and be
violent
you know what's really interesting about
you saying that is um so like i was
studying
this thing called zip flaw zipf
law and it's basically this algorithm
that you can put towards
any language and it will show whether
it's a natural language or not so all
human languages follow this law music
also follows this law
and it's the same with our our genetic
code and so this started coming into
what's now called
um linguistic genetics
that's showing the way we use words even
thinking words
they it works in the same way that our
genes do and our words actually have
epigenetic effects on our dna wow and so
when you're saying that about a.i let me
talk into the mic when you're saying
that about a.i
there's something about what it's trying
to do is keep your focus
keep your attention like you know what
you focus a lot of attention on you know
that your body starts to become
engaged in that and so there's there's
something is
almost hypnosis in fact it absolutely is
hypnosis when you can focus your body
and your mind on one thing
spiritual traditions had it where you
you breathe and you focus on a light or
something like that
nowadays it's these articles he was just
talking while you were pissing or
whatever you were doing yeah thanks
i feel better yeah like so basically i
was saying that we're getting to the
point where
you can have a human just input a few
things like let's say today
ian uh did a back flip to the right ian
back flipped
and i say it's racist enter and then the
ai can
generate a long-winded thing where it's
just like today i was reading an article
and i heard about this guy ian who did a
backflip
now why am i so angry about it so all of
those things that sound human
that are telling a story could be just
artificially generated and what happens
then is
the ai will then auto generate this
article based on actually
it's like ryan long's sketch are you
familiar with ryan long the comedian
yeah he did that bit where it's like
blank has a blank
problem and then he's and then he showed
all these ridiculous articles where it's
like
you know swimming has a transphobia
problem and
and like basketball has a gender problem
like you just
buzzwords that formula exists
an ai could easily fill in the gaps once
you make that
that sentence and what'll end up
happening is the ai will auto generate
the article i'm sure these things exist
already
and then they'll try and see how much
traffic it gets
how long people are staying reading it
and if it does and then they'll keep
tweaking it
and then they'll make another version
it'll do a little bit worse they'll make
another version it'll
version they'll do a little bit better
they'll keep that version they'll keep
iterating and learning and then
eventually you will find the perfect
rage made content being masked produced
for profit
to keep people in a perpetual state of
anger and anxiety
and you're making me think of
procedurally generated video games as
well as artificial intelligence
builds out our digital realm and they're
like this guy likes to turn right
a lot so let's give him a lot of right
turns in his game to keep him playing
this game
and to keep him engaged in my meditative
trance that i want him
to hang into imagine imagine this in
your phones
there's this motion sensor and there's
out of aston university i think his name
is max
little i think he's a mathematician he
found that people you know they
they keep their phones in their pockets
and it can
sense your gait cycle the way you walk
and with that data they found
now this there hasn't been a huge study
on it but a hundred percent
accurate diagnosis of neurodegenerative
diseases like alzheimer's
multiple sclerosis better than a doctor
sitting and trying to diagnose you for
the same
because the motion sensor that's already
in your phone so this is just
like the failure of imagination is not
realizing
how you can figure out from a motion
sensor
you know neurodegenerative disease and
diagnose it
imagine now ai helping us get better at
figuring out how we can use the
technology that's already here
so then i heard that facebook was
working on something that could predict
your thoughts
literally predict your thoughts and so
all their users all the data predict
your thoughts
what you're going to type in what you're
going to look for and that's what this
thing called sentient world simulation
is
you know so it's a digital mirror of the
you know
our whole world all the data points
everything connected to the internet of
things eventually the internet of bodies
which is basically just
harvesting biometric data it's the
matrix
here's the crazy thing about the matrix
in the movie
you have this ai that they say they
tried to craft a utopian matrix but
humans rejected it because they're
predisposed to conflict
what they don't consider is that we're
watching the construction
of this matrix and it's going to be
absolutely perfect in every
way you are going to be completely
entranced by it
it's going to know exactly what you want
when you want it what to say when to say
it to keep you locked in that state
we talk about you mention video games
where they're like hey let's this guy
likes to for some reason he jumps a
whole lot
let's give him a platformer let's make
him let's make him have to work for it
and enjoy it
they figure out what you want so you
keep doing it what happens when we get
to the point where we have neural link
when our social media is already doing
this our social media is already trying
to feed us
what they know will keep our eyes locked
on that page it's making everyone go
insane
what happens when they figure out how to
make it perfect
that you will never unplug from neural
you end up rejecting it this has been my
experience the last week i've been
really hitting the game's heart and i'm
getting to a point where i'll sit
and stare at my computer and think i
have no joy from this because this is
not
real conflict but this is real concept
norm
i don't know i'm just i'm just you're
explaining that we're not there yet
at a certain point the ai's gonna figure
out how to overcome that hurdle
and they're gonna be like how did we
lose this guy you leaving you gave them
all the data they needed to figure it
out
but they showed you all of these things
let's let's say you're sitting at a
computer and they're feeding you a
random number generator
and then they they served you the
numbers 1 17 83 and 52.
and at 52 you've got up and walked out
the ai doesn't know or care it's a it's
a simple machine
and they're gonna say don't give anybody
52. and they're going to slowly figure
out and the next person leaves at 52
anyway
and they're going to figure out what
they need to do in this game to prevent
you
from feeling like you're not
accomplished like in the movie the
matrix people
rejected it anyway even though it was
perfect they still just they need
conflict they need you must understand
the ai would then give you that conflict
they would create it what i'm telling
you is
you are not going to be able to escape
from a perfect trance
the system will see you leave when you
left that video game it collected all
the data as to what you did
when you did it and what they gave you
and they'll say we did something wrong
and they will adapt and the next person
is playing they will slightly change it
eventually out of the thousands of
people who are playing this particular
game
the i'm not saying the exit exists right
now i'm saying
when we get to that point eventually
with a thousand people playing
they'll make a certain amount of
iterations where it'll discover we
figured out
figured out how to get a person to play
for another minute longer
then they'll evolve better iteration
eventually you have you'll have people
strapped in the machine saying
there's absolutely no reason to leave
food being one of them for sure but if
we're talking about a singularity
in artificial intelligence we're talking
about
robots that do work for us that change
that do everything you know
for for our bidding then the ai will
eventually start having food delivered
for you
so you think you will never leave there
the grand majority of people will
eventually just give over to the matrix
as they did in the movie but then there
will be a small extreme that is just not
satisfied that for whatever reason the
human brain's quantum calculator is
greater than any ai we could build
i don't think so and i pull out of it i
think humans
evolved for very specific circumstances
and
one of the interesting things about
humans as an apex predator
is that adaptation through our
intelligence
allowed us to essentially evolve faster
than evolution would permit
basically when you look at a lion
chasing uh gazelle right is that what
they eat
gazelle yeah i'm not you know an animal
amongst many other animals
well the gazelle has to run fast and the
lion has to run faster the
line has to be stronger and so there's
this uh natural selection there's a
competition
humans instead of evolving to become
faster to beat out the gazelle evolve to
become smarter
so what happens is because we can
develop tools
there is no evolutionary strategy for
any animal which can escape our power
nothing we have conquered everything
every other life form on this planet
even diseases now granted they can
evolve and we're in a constant war
against diseases
but humans are the apex predator
and it's because evolution is too slow
for us
but what that also means is humans are
still
animals who have adapted for very
specific circumstances
these the technology that we've built
adapts faster than life can adapt to it
which means we will potentially develop
a technology
which we will we'll victimize ourselves
with we will create an
ai that won't seek to destroy us like
the terminator or the matrix won't go to
war with it
there could theoretically be a war in
the sense that the ai will be a mindless
in a sense automaton seeking to give
humans everything they've ever wanted
and there will be a few people who maybe
break out of it for some reason or
another can't be plugged in
and they'll be desperately trying to
free people from this matrix but people
will be like get away from me i know i'm
in the matrix i love being in the matrix
you go live in your garbage world i have
everything i could possibly ever i ever
want
and that's what humans will get wrapped
up wrapped up into and then they will
just
fall apart unless of course the true
singularity means that the ai can
replicate machines
which can manipulate digits replicate
themselves expand their own technology
in which case humans will just become a
remnant i suppose
and then in tens of thousands of years
or hundreds of thousands of years
there will just be self-replicating
machines floating through the universe
replicating on various planets and no
human insight and when you say years
that's basically
the time that it takes to travel a
distance so like time is just relative
i mean not to diverge too far off but
when you say
10 000 years from now you could just
mean it a certain distance away from us
right now that is happening
that's that it takes 10 000 years to get
there whether or not
time is passing you're sitting here
you're going there
it's there like what what what i mean
it's an extreme it's this isn't the
conversation
it may be that we create a system that
self-replicates
and humans just eventually cease to
exist and then the universe gets
populated by self-replicating machines
with no
real consciousness with no real drive or
passions
and that's it and they colonize the
galaxy and people
yeah and then and then you know what you
end up with you end up with like some
moderately primitive civilization like
minor
minding their own business and then str
a strange cube lands on their planet
starts just wiping everything out and
you know terraforming it for no reason
for a human for a human race that
doesn't exist anymore
unless psychedelics are that x factor
you mentioned we're talking about dmt
earlier that's like that's a great segue
well here's the reason why i want to say
that there's a really interesting book
called what technology wants and it
talks about evolution
and it says there's two main camps and
one is the contingency theory the other
is the
inevitability theory one is that
contingency things just happen because
at the moment that's the best tool it
had to arrive at
a random meandering into whatever
direction
that billiard ball shot the other one
off into the other one
is that everything inevitably is
converging towards like
no matter what we humans were going to
be evolved here even if you rewound and
started over over and over again
during the metazoan period there's the
eyes
evolved 40 times i believe and different
kinds of eyes have
continually been evolved and these are
immaculate even darwin was just like
there's something interesting about
the eye anything less out of it and it
wouldn't work as beautifully as it does
so inevitabl inevitably what this guy is
saying is
in what technology wants awesome book
he's saying that
technology is also inevitable and the
way we build it
it's also at a population density we get
to a point where this
will always happen what's happening on
the planet right now
and and just just to finish this off
what i find
super interesting is one of the tech
hubs of the world silicon valley
what was that area very popular for
during the awakening
hate ashbury yeah the psychedelic
transits
and a lot of those people actually went
on to being
techies so timothy leary huge into
talking about
you know psychedelics this is how we
turn on a generation
by the end of his life he was talking
about a.i and he was talking about
future tech
terence mckenna was doing the same thing
so i i do feel like
i do feel like what you were saying
might have a little bit of merit that
most people will be fine and they are
the the ones who were heard
or group think really they just want to
be part of the group and then there's
the outliers like
you'll you'll find outliers even among
you know chimps or
orangutans where like they they study
these chimps and they're like why are
they
so depressed they're always hanging out
way outside and they they took these
outliers and they studied them and then
they brought them back
and it turns out that their entire tribe
were murdered because they were they're
outliers the ones who were different
they stayed on the outside of the group
they're also the early warning signs of
external threats interesting and so the
interesting thing is i wonder if there
is an x factor and psychedelics
potentially they seem to be this thing
where like there's intelligence in
nature
i believe there really is intelligence
in nature
you know call it just it it you know
uses an algorithm to know how to grow
towards the sunlight
and somehow synergize and harmonize with
the mycelium blanket and
it really is this closed-loop system
that found a way
to just survive there's an algorithm
this
very same um equation that um
accounts for the uh what is that
mandelbrot set
that kind of infinity loop that you know
generator
is the very same equation that accounts
for how
um populations especially like rabbit
populations
they balance themselves they go to a
peak and then they balance themselves
and it's always something it's some
external thing whether it's a predator
or you know the environment something
keeps it in check
it's this closed-loop system is that the
fibonacci sequence the mandelbrot set
no difference different equation that's
different yeah
let me tell you something crazy you
mentioned that like the eye
was like essentially some some believe
was an inevitability
then it stands to reason that if we ever
encounter
extra extraterrestrial intelligence they
will look very very much like us
for several reasons one we evolved on a
planet where we have an oxygen-rich
environment
but not too oxygen-rich which means we
have the ability to manipulate fire
which allows us to separate certain
elements and create various components
it allows us to create technology it
allows us to refine minerals and
ultimately build rocket ships and other
technology and intelligent species
say the dolphin they're fairly smart
they don't got hands they're underwater
there's no fire by which to smelt
anything
and there's no hands by which to
manipulate things out of all the life
that may exist in the universe assuming
it does
the ones that succeed in developing
technology will probably be in a similar
environment or at least in a certain
capacity
have the ability to manipulate elements
to create components and advance
technology and have the ability to
manipulate small things
so it's entirely possible that eyes will
evolve the ability to sense the visible
spectrum as we call it
the ability to have some kind of
fingertips so that you can
use smaller tools and make very refined
computers and
microchips and things like that and
probably i would say oxygen makes a lot
of sense because the ability to control
fire so
they breathe similar things to us they
look particularly different
who knows what their skin might be like
maybe their son is is is you know
bigger smaller maybe they're further
away from it or whatever maybe they like
certain temperatures
but you look at the boiling point the
freezing point of water where there's
water there tends to be life
i think they would be extremely similar
to humans maybe
uh we see symmetry in nature they may
have two arms
they may have four and no legs and their
arms function you know
interchangeably but they'll still be
able to use fine tools
like they could have a darker star so
they're not as
light focused maybe they're more
receptive to heat although i don't know
if it's if
what's more base heat or light well you
have to think about the freezing point
boiling point of water yeah hydrogen's
pervasive
they would likely exist in a similar
temperature set that we do
now i i do think it can be a bit
simplistic to
to to think that because there's
probably things we haven't discovered
yet
there's probably ways by which someone
some you know
species could eventually discover a way
to isolate certain elements and develop
components without using fire
so based on our current technology we
can make that assumption they must be in
some way
similar to our atmosphere or whatever
like i think that's fair to say
but there was i believe in the past 20
years they used to think the components
for life
were based on exactly what we were
they're like oh here's everything that
life has
but they were looking only at earth and
then there was a revision saying
instead of saying they need water how
about we say there needs to be some kind
of base by which
chemicals can mix and interchange it
doesn't need to be water so it could be
something else theoretically
but i think it's fair to say and you
know there's a good chance that
assuming there is alien life and i think
the universe is certainly big enough to
warrant it
they will actually be fairly similar to
us they won't speak english like they do
in the marvel movies
but like in the star trek you know show
they're all fairly humanoid
they all look different they have
different heads it is a little over the
top how they all are basically people
but their foreheads are a little
different
but you look at some of the alien races
and bipedal humanoid type structure
it probably i think there's a decent
probability of it maybe not a guarantee
you mentioned the bipedal part um
there's symmetry in
you know just about all organisms
you know so that symmetry is very
interesting because like to produce two
of everything it helps the way we move
and orient to gravity but it also it's
like dna
can be more efficient just repeat the
same thing on the other side
mirror it and so they go into that and
they also speak about like contingency
and inevitability they it's not one or
the other it's it's yes and like
contingency you were saying um how
maybe they found another way to get to a
point that we did maybe they they made
jumps and strides and their
main point in the book is that
technology is the main thing that does
that
like we we have this contingency where
it's like
it usually it happens very slow but
technology it can make
huge strides because something else you
know very intelligent is is working on
giving it those
it can jump a bunch of generations that
we had to go through in the slow way
so contingency is the way that it
happens
and inevitability is where it's going
right so i know i'm going to california
but where how i get there that's
dependent upon the roads in the truck i
want to know what else is a very large
component
that will i believe i believe there's a
likelihood that
assuming there is extraterrestrial
intelligence they will be similar to us
not identical but they will also be a
very war-like species
the reason for it is war is natural
competition between the intelligent
a war between humans and deer ends very
predictably
hunters go out in hunting season and
sweep the fields and wipe out what they
call pests
a lot of deer no longer exist however
humans up against humans means that when
one human develops
gun powder the other human has to
quickly adapt
and because they're intelligent the
conflict goes from being between species
to between different tribes within the
same species that conflict results in a
rapid development of technology
because if you don't compete
successfully with the new arms and the
new weapons
you die and you get wiped out so you
take a look at europe for instance
and the proximity of all these warring
countries and the rapid development of
their technology
that war drove a lot of technological
advancement
resulting in a lot of things people
probably take for granted
space program was had a lot to do with
the cold war
and we developed a lot of new
technologies plastics for instance
we're heavily influenced i think with
the space race trying to find lighter
and stronger materials
and now we all benefit the benefits of
that
any other species not i should slow down
a little bit many other species
on in in a different planet if they're
living freely and peacefully say avatar
you know the movie avatar
that actually was was particularly
intelligent they weren't very
advanced they had bows and arrows and i
know it's probably just a movie cliche
that they're trying to make them look
like native americans or indigenous
population you know as primitive
but the reality is based on their world
where they could all communicate
inter with each with eat with different
species that would present
less of an opportunity for for conflict
because they weren't a particularly
warlike species and were very
you know pro nature they didn't develop
a lot of these technologies
so uh i'm not an expert on this stuff
i'm not an anthropologist or anything
but i was reading about why it is that
the various tribes of native americans
in north america
weren't as advanced as say europeans in
terms of gunpowder and ships
and it's because the country the north
america was so massive that when a
conflict would arise
certain tribes could just leave and so
there was an opportunity to escape
as opposed to fight and when given the
opportunity most animals choose
most living beings choose no conflict
so even a bear a grizzly bear you know
they don't want to fight you
if you're threatening their children
they might if they're starving they
might
but in europe where it was settled for a
long time and you had basically people
pushed to the edges
they were it was i'm going to war with
you and taking what you got or else
and then they just became very
competitive whereas native americans
were like
yes there was a lot of war absolutely
but a lot of tribes could just be like
we better get out of here it's better to
run than fight
maybe it's possible we're only war-like
because we're all stuck on this planet
with nowhere to run
and if we were able to spread out
infinitely that we would
let go of that like star trek they they
they're they the federation becomes much
less war-like
and most of the you know in in the show
the enterprise is a science vessel
it does have military capabilities
because you got to defend yourself from
threats and there is war
but yeah i guess the issue is when you
look at say the movie avatar and these
imaginations of what a species would be
like if they didn't have conflict
why would we have any reason to develop
technology if we're comfortable
and peaceful right you need to create
the conflict within yourself why i like
psychedelics if you've ever taken
psychedelics you know
you have to face yourself the natural
conflict of nature the
what have i done wrong maybe that's
that's will keep us
building and creating if we force
ourselves to
work the muscle of the mind and
psychedelics uh you know
it is a technology you know it's just
the way we use it it is it is
a technology shamanism is a technology
and like there's a very
accurate point to this when you take
psychedelics what i believe the main
thing that you're doing is you're
amplifying the here and the now
the set and setting that you're around
your mindset is being amplified all
all of your emotions your subconscious
is being amplified
it's shown that those you know the
reptilian brain the
mammalian brain the neocortex the all
the filters between them
they go so your subconscious is emerging
and then so
shamanic tribes what they would do is
they would have some kind of a rattle
and they would get like a rhythm
going and and then they would sing they
would use the voice and there's
something about
the melody and the rhythm and the use of
song which they say they got from the
plants
that's a technology that destabilizes
what's called the default mode network
and that's where they say
the ego lies let's talk about this
extended state dmt
stuff so we had alex jones and michael
malus on this show
and a lot of talk about dmt yeah
and gorillas that's right and ishmael
which uh which ian has right there thank
you very much
for those that are josh for sending me a
copy of ishmael for those that aren't
familiar
the meme i am a gorilla which we sell
the shirt go to timcast.com click shop
and you get your i am a gorilla t-shirt
it's based off of alex jones saying this
book ishmael is
a psychic gorilla telling people that
they're like you know destroying the
planet
and so alex kept saying you know i'm a
gorilla and then the gorilla emoji
happened then we made the shirt as a
joke but
we have the book so uh anyway in this
conversation we were having there was
talk of the elves
breaking through the veil you take dmp
dmt and you take enough you blast off
and the interesting thing about this
conversation the thing that that really
you know excites me is this idea there's
been studies where people had
shared experiences they all take dmt
and you'd think if the drug was an
internal chemical effect on your brain
well then everyone's brain is going to
be different but people reported seeing
basically the same things
now these trips are limited but you were
you're telling me about about extended
state dmt
what's going on with this so if any of
uh your listeners
know dr rick strasman he wrote dmt the
spirit molecule
what he did was there was a long
prohibition on psychedelics
and then he was the first in the u.s to
break through that prohibition
and he basically just said i want to
inject people with high amounts of dmt
and see what happens it was very very
simple and they're like
all right approved broke through that so
they injected them in a clinical setting
with high amounts of dmt
and these people would have the very
same acceleration
there's this crescendo and then you
blast through some kind of a
what can only be described as like an
other dimensional or at least a
psychological
barrier and you blast through into
another world the veil
the veil and so the interesting thing
was uh
in a lot of people who speak about this
there's hundreds of thousands of trip
reports
or at least many many thousands i should
say of trip reports
of people saying when you get to this
world
it is not it's it's not just a
distortion of this world it's not just
like you're seeing
pink elephants in the road but the road
is is this world
you seem to be in a completely different
place but it's structured
it's not just very weird and amorphous
it's very structured
and the beings that you meet there the
people come back
and say like listen i've done ayahuasca
i've done you know peyote i've done
mushrooms
you meet different things and i can't
tell if it's just part of my own psyche
but in the dmt space
this was not me this was at absolutely
not me they're very very intelligent
a lot of the times they're insectoid um
sometimes they call them machine elves
or clockwork elves
they have mechanical aspects to them um
you know short very small sometimes very
weird
um joe rogan talks about it a lot but
they they fall into certain categories
so there is some kind of like
repetition or like an archetype to what
people experience in this realm
michael malus said they're like slinkys
like they're made of like a wireframe
spiraling kind of structure of some sort
i've heard of that i've heard they're
like
elves made of like you know tin cans and
sometimes like trash sometimes crystals
um but there's really only a few
categories it's not like you know oh
well i i saw you know like this actor or
you know whatever like a 3 000
foot bigfoot they usually fall within
the same categories
and the interesting thing about this is
that the extended state dmt
so i just did a film called dmt
quest and i'll talk about that in a
little bit but dmt quest is all about
endogenous dmt which means we produce
dmt inside of our own brain
and we haven't known why it's very
interesting like it's there
um all the time it's being produced
throughout the brain
in far higher amounts than we originally
thought there was a bunch of people that
said yeah but it's not enough to make
enough sense of it but we show in dmt
quest um with john chavez the
the founder of it that it's being
produced
about how much serotonin and dopamine we
have in the brain that's how much dmt
we're making you know it's comparable
levels so the interesting thing is is
like we
we know it's already in there maybe it's
a part of how we
see reality how we experience reality
rick strasman said
everybody who comes back from a megadose
of dmt they say
whatever that was that was more real
than this reel
that felt more real than this and that's
that's something that happened over and
over again and these
volunteers they weren't talking to one
another so the people who took the dmt
said the trip the place they went to
felt more like reality
it felt more familiar it felt more real
and and is just
more real than real that felt more real
than this real and that was a lot of
people saying that
so this you know now compounded on you
know
this was in the 90s dr xrasman was doing
this so
now the there's this awesome guy anton
bilton
he um he's the one who funded dmt quest
and he also is the one who funded
um imperial college london to do
extended state dmt
basically that's taking i think it's
called the henry boyle machine it's like
an anesthesiology machine where it's a
continuous infusion
into your bloodstream now of dmt
and it has already started so i don't
know like
yes they're gathering data but it's
probably not going to be out for a
couple years it takes a while for it to
come out
but just imagine so the reason why
they're doing this is because
dmt is very fast acting they call it the
the lunchman's
psychedelic because you can go to lunch
do dmt and when you're back
there's no real afterglow it's not like
oh man i need to take a day off
you're just back you're 100 back but
with like a what the
like that's how you're feeling so when
these people were doing these very deep
trips blasting off could they interact
with
the real world could they like sit up
and be like hey yo i'm not feeling too
well can you get me out of this chair or
were they just like zonked out
it's a good question could they maybe
um so theoretically i've done it
and theoretically i've gotten up in the
middle of it so can you
yes do you want to know it's more
interesting
in there it's it's not interesting to be
in this world
while you're having that experience you
want to just kind of stay
super chill low light it can get very
aggravating
a lot of light a lot of noise so your
sentence setting it has to hold the
space for you to be wherever
you are so like sensory deprivation some
people have done that
that sounds trippy or something like
that literally you know aubrey mark is
just that i think i forget how
six days in complete darkness and you
start having
almost dmt like visuals in that kind of
respect
so you could probably compound it like
that but imagine this appear
imperial college london they're doing
extended state dmt
why because 15 minutes in that space is
not enough
and we need to talk to whatever these
beings are
so this is a major university that's
like
well there's so many there's so much
anecdotal evidence we need to figure out
what's going on in that space because
what if
these actually are interdimensional
beings that are here we just
never see it because the veil is here we
see a small sliver of of the
light spectrum all of a sudden you have
to all of a sudden you start to
understand what alex jones was trying to
say on joe rogan when he was yelling
about the interdimensional beings and
all this stuff going on
and you're like what are you talking
about it's like crazy you slow down
and you explain people do dmt they
experience something that is
rel is fairly shared among people
and that that is what really makes me
say like
i want to know what this is because when
i when i hear people talk about ghosts i
remember there's like a coffee shop by
me when i was a little kid and they were
like oh it's haunted someone once got
pushed down the stairs and i'm like dude
i'm more likely to believe someone
pushed him down the stairs
and it wasn't the ghost who pushed
around there's someone who didn't like
him you know what i mean
but when you tell me that a university
put a bunch of people in the chair you
know
shot them full dmt and they all had a
very very similar experience
i have two thoughts one i think it's
it's reasonable that maybe it's just
because we're all human
that our brains react the same way
creating a similar experience
or perhaps there's something more to it
maybe we're shattering through this veil
and we're seeing something beyond
reality that truly does exist
you know before people realized there
was a charged electromagnetic spectrum
they did not know it existed or could
even fathom what it was
and then we were like hey yo guess what
radio waves now we can communicate
by just like a signal being sent out
with electromagnetic pulses
you know what what i really love about
this is that you guys are saying they
keep experiencing
the same type of things either it's
mechanical um insectoid
you said beings of light sometimes or
small creatures like
elvish things so there it is possible
there are species throughout the
universe that have evolved
and they were one of them was an
insectoid species one of them was a
small
hominid or a small one of them was a a
mechanical society that is like an
advanced ai and one is just pure light
that is
conscious that is that's possible what
if this has happened
over and over and over again and when
we're talking about inevitability
like what if it's inevitable that we
explore maybe it's not always called
psychedelics but
it's inevitable that we explore beyond
the veil of our own limitation and
that's what evolution is is
we realize there's actually something
universal that
we're all connected to carl jung called
it the collective unconscious
some call it the you know like the akash
i don't know how much i
like i under even understand about those
terms but what if it is inevitable
that breaking out of what's called the
default mode network all psychedelics do
that and the default mode network is
it's consuming like 60 50 to 60 percent
of all of our biological energy at least
in our brain
when we're just ruminating and
daydreaming it's it's some say it's not
efficient maybe it does serve a purpose
but psychedelics break you out of that
and this is how people are saying
psychedelics are
helping people with intractable
depression
anxiety things like eating disorders
obsessive-compulsive disorder
post-traumatic stress
um tbi there's a like unlimited sciences
there's a group out of boulder
who's you know who basically brought up
to the ufc
you know because there's so many so much
traumatic brain injury
that psilocybin mushrooms potentially
working with johns hopkins university is
saying like
we need to actually dose some of these
fighters with psilocybin because it's
helping
neurogenesis they're regrowing brain
patterns back
low doses of dmt actually help for
stroke so imagine
dmt might be actually really really
important in the brain
we just don't know why yet so we're
sitting here speculating on it we're all
on dmt by the way everyone in here and
everyone listening we're on dmt
it's just sub psychedelic you mean like
naturally occurring
naturally occurring endogenous we don't
want to give the kids the impression
that we all smoke no
no you're definitely right about
different show effects very different
very different all plans
check this out what if we were talking
before about you know mmorpg
reality are you know is this existence
full of
billions of humans who are all sentient
conscious entities
are only some people scientists content
conscious entities
or is it only you listening to this show
what if this experience people are
having where they say it's more real
than reality
what if that's just like when you're not
playing the game
so uh have you guys you've seen the rick
and morty episode where they go to uh
blitz and chits i think it's called
and he plays the game called roy and he
basically puts on his headset
and then lives a full life as a guy
named roy
and then he loses when he's like in his
old age gets crushed by a carpet
and then all of a sudden he like comes
back to the the game the arcade
and he's like wait who am i i'm i'm
morty like
what if that's what it is what if the
reality is you're getting
a you're not really blasting off like
you are but you're not really breaking
through
it's just like you're temporarily
looking back at the real world where
you're playing this video game that is
humans on earth and it's a temporary
glimpse because dmt doesn't actually
take you out of the game you're still
alive
you know what's really interesting is
because like we can access it and we can
turn it up i believe we can it's not
proven yet but like
wim hof the dutchman he holds 26
guinness world records he has a
breathing technique that allows him to
swim under polar ice caps he's ran a
marathon
in the arctic circle as well as in the
sahara desert without drinking any water
he's climbed to the top of mount everest
in sandals and shorts
because of this breathing technique and
so that's what made
john chavez and i when we were making
dmt quests we took a wim hof
breathing instructor and we sat him in a
chair and we had him hooked up to eeg
machines
and we just had him do the breath and we
looked at the eeg profile and it looks
to our understanding and to what we've
compared it to
identical to the dmt eeg profile
that's correct so like so this is now
we're talking about human potential how
do you access the dmt
and why so wim hof is saying we are
helping people with their intractable
depression anxiety ptsd
you know ocd you know all that kind of
stuff the same thing that psychedelics
were doing so you you also
who is it salvador dali somebody said do
you take drugs and he said i
am drugs you just have to know how to
access it like we
produce it so now it's like is there
drugs is such a harsh word but is there
a
real purpose to alter your consciousness
if we get into such like
biases and like rigid thinking is it
healthy to break ourselves out in a
healthy way
not too often because that that could
lead to its own addiction or messiah
complex
but you know is it healthy to break
ourselves out of
rigid thinking and then come back
integrate back into normal life what if
there was a way to actually focus your
mind
into mass producing dmt to access
blasting off or breaking through the
veil completely on your own
just through training and exercise and
practice visualizations and
you guys have seen doctor strange the
movie negative when uh so doctor so he's
like you know his hands are all messed
up and he's trying to find a cure and he
goes to
uh kamertage and he meets the ancient
one and she grabs his head
and then also he blasts off and he's
like flying through space
what if there was a way to train
yourself because your body does produce
dmt
and you mentioned this guy who does this
breathing technique what if he's
like it's like rudimentary access to
this ability to like
control yourself and what if humans
actually could reach that point through
training and meditation
to actually be able to experience dmt
trips just by thought
i really think that governments are
already doing that you know
and like so i've seen in russia i've
seen in china i've also
seen in um in the united states
documentation from the department of the
army in the 19 i think it was 1983 where
they were looking
at um what's called from the monroe
institute number the gateway experience
it's called the gateway experience i
have this documentation where they're
like
we really need to understand hypnosis
and the power of focusing the body and
the mind at the same time
and how you can remote view telepathy
telekinesis
thera goats right so that's that's
definitely an aspect of it but beyond
that that like we know that remote
viewers help
in um criminal cases is that true
yeah that's crazy no no i mean look at
look it up i mean
it's it's not something that i
personally have the documentation on but
the so remote viewers helping solve
crimes they have been brought in they
have been brought to help
and and you know you can't prove but it
seems like they
have actually helped that there's
actually been um
some cases that were solved and there's
this guy
um something campbell i want to say tom
campbell
my big toe he wrote and he teaches
people how to do remote viewing
you know i got an article about in 1979
half a dozen
psychics working inside fort meade were
on more than 200 occasions trying to
peer through the ether to see where the
hostages in the iranian crisis were
being held was it successful
uh i don't i don't know i don't know i
have to read the whole thing have you
even heard of like
local crimes like kidnappings and stuff
like that
you know where a remote viewer was
brought in um
you know i'll have to i'll have to check
that out more but i do know that
governments have been studying this
they they at least want to know you know
and
and i also i i absolutely believe that
the reason why we're having major
universities
looking at psychedelics and things like
that is because
we the wim hof you know the super
soldiers in china and stuff like that a
lot of it does have to do with the mind
and wim hof
what did he repurpose you know now i
have to give all the credit to wim hof
because no one was
talking about tumo or different like
yoga breaths and stuff like that
but there was a whole like yoga is one
of the longest lasting disciplines
movement disciplines and they focus
their body in their mind
with breath if i were to if i told you
that through legitimate real yoga
not like you know suburban housewife
yoga a man
could live for 200 years would you
believe it i would and i've heard enough
stories
of it i was going to bring this up i was
waiting i was like i'll bring it up in a
second because i knew a guy he was a
high krishna
and he was telling me stories about what
yoga really is he was like kind of
perturbed he was like
i'm really angry that all of these like
suburban housewives are treating yoga
like it's just stupid exercise man it's
like spiritual it's what you eat it's
what you live it's what you experience
and he goes i'm telling you man in india
there are yogis who are 200 years
old and i said get out of here dude
that's no there's no way come on man
and he was like i'm telling you man they
go up to the mountains and they meditate
and they do yoga and they live for
hundreds of years and i don't
i don't believe it i didn't believe it i
don't want to say i do believe it now
but
when i this was a long time ago i was
like 18. i started reading about
um caloric deprivation are you familiar
yeah so we've extended we've like
doubled the lifespan of what mice
by just giving them the bare minimum of
food they would need
and i read this really great quote they
were like there's like a scientist who
said
it's remarkable we've doubled the
doubled the lifespan of the av
of the average mouse though i wouldn't
call it living because basically the
mouse was being
just from the brink of starvation but
because of that
the mouse lived for a long time they did
it with worms and others and other
animals
so when i saw that i started thinking
like what if this this guy was telling
the truth that there's like some yogis
and because all they do all day is just
sit
and they barely eat they eat just enough
and they do nothing but meditate as he
described
well that just sounds like caloric
deprivation and perhaps they could
live to be much much longer because
they're literally not doing anything
other than living within their own mind
yeah have you heard that mice with a
much faster metabolism and higher
um heart rate have roughly the same
exact amount of breaths and heartbeats
as an elephant does
1.5 million really 1.5 million so maybe
and that's true is it same for humans
too i i would imagine i would imagine
and there's this book by greg braden i'm
forgetting i have it in my phone
but basically he says he was talking
about longevity
and he was saying there's this one guy
in china and you it's on the books
the the chinese military celebrated his
100th birthday 150th birthday and 200th
birthday
and when he was and he had like 200
something children 14
wives and so it's documented
and what he said and this was in the
greg braden book i wish i could remember
the dude's name
but when they were asking him like what
is your secret he said
i only eat medicinal plants from my own
property
and i do and he was a tai chi master he
does tai chi
so these are movement practices of
slowing the breath down but becoming
more efficient
because when you hear about breath
practice you're like oh you need to
breathe a lot
actually when you when you learn how to
breathe correctly
you breathe less and you're more your
body is more efficient
and so there's got to be something to
that but then there's also amazing
technology that's doing things with
longevity and i believe
there's something with technology and
psychedelics i believe are just
helping people understand our own
potential and
there's this technology i think i was
telling you about it earlier
ebner and scorsh so that's e-b-n-e-r
and these are german scientists they put
basically fern seeds um corn
seeds and then rainbow trout eggs
under an electrostatic field so this is
the same kind of effect that
right before a thunderstorm you would
get but 10 000 volts
and then they planted the seeds and
hatched those eggs
the wood fern had a phenotype meaning
the way its genes expressed itself
expressed itself like a fern
that has been extinct for 150 million
years and
i'm trying to think of the name of the
article but it was something about like
high voltage
something causes for gene regression
back into
an extinct phenotype the same thing with
the corn
where corn now because of selective
breeding only one ear comes off of any
node
they were starting to get five uh ears
off of every node which is how corn used
to be back before the selective breeding
the rainbow trout was the most
interesting one it started
it was more stocky it had a broader jaw
better color it didn't need antibiotics
and it resembled a rainbow trout that's
been extinct for 150 years
so maybe what was really happening all
that long time ago was
electrostatic storms or something maybe
i mean like there's something about the
regression of genes though back into
extinct species and like
i don't exactly know how that would
relate so for for that my understanding
is that
uh chickens for instance there was i
watched where they said like they could
actually grow teeth and chickens by
injecting an enzyme
into like when it's like in the egg in
an embryo or whatever and it's because
at some point in the evolutionary
process
that the chicken stopped producing this
enzyme and then
you know what came first chicken or the
egg but the new evolution was that
the enzyme was less so the teeth didn't
happen
and so by reintroducing it the the code
for that still exists
it yeah yeah it's interesting it's crazy
stuff
totally totally and there's there's
something about that and i like do you
do you think how much hybrid creatures
do you think
militaries and in with black budgets or
i bet they've gone
nuts right they're chimeras yeah so
there was this
um one so there's a video and i'll have
to i'll send you guys the link of it
it's this woman named ulrika
granocha she's german she was really
into the work the russian scientist of
peter gaiav
she did this for the solari report
report.com
and it was this video where she showed
there was this um
i think he was a japanese guy and he
used this dodecahedron shape
cauldron and so he took the the genetic
vibratory imprint of ducks and he he
irradiated a chicken egg with it
and that chicken egg once hatched
started having features of the duck and
he reversed it and did the same thing
the other way around so like i mean i
don't know where that's gone but you
know they didn't just
you know governments around the world
didn't just go oh that's interesting
let's just forget it
you were talking about ghost what was a
ghost dna uh how did you well is the
phantom dna experiment that was peter
gayaev where he put dna into a vacuum
tube
they irradiated it with photons with a
laser
those photons then aligned themselves to
the double helix structure
then they removed the dna they removed
the glass beaker everything from
there and they looked at that same spot
and the photons were stuck in place
for a month so the photons these tiny
particles of light were still stuck and
they call that the phantom dna
experiment
iona and alan miller said this can only
be explained by wormholes
what so the dna apparently has
microscopic wormholes that brings in its
vibratory informational imprint from
either outside of spacetime or elsewhere
in the galaxy beyond the veil beyond the
veil
well i would love to know what's behind
the veil but how about we uh take some
super chats and we'll ask the people
what they think
lies beyond the veil don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe at the
notification bell
and go to timcast.com become a member
because we always have those amazing
exclusive members only segments that
will be up sometimes even full episodes
but uh again smash the like button let's
read what y'all guys have to say
euler's workshop says how have you not
talked about bill gates
being the largest owner of farmland in
the u.s yet also i make hyper real
miniatures hit me up yay
we have yeah luke won't shut up about it
seriously
looks like you guys bill gates bought
all the farms we're like we know luke
now he's on vacation i guess so if you
guys are mad that luke's not here just
yeah go to the floor tweet at him and
say what are you doing
let's see viva la tortu
says tim did you see glenn beck's video
yesterday about banks starting to use
esgs
basically social credit systems to
determine your credit worthiness ooh
creepy your credit worthiness yeah this
is really really great
when you mentioned william casey i knew
that someone had a super chat already
right when we started the show
enlightened worms said william casey cia
director 1981-1987
quote we'll know our disinformation
program is complete
when everything the american public
believes is false
and then he mentions brennan but i'm not
going to read what he said about him but
yeah
not complimentary make 1984 fiction
again says
says give ian the keys for this one oh
yeah i mean
absolutely code red says studio upgrade
recommendation
create a lab space for ian in his area
so we can do experiments during the show
live and get him a lab coat spin the
gorilla he needs a lab coat for sure
yeah we can't spend the gorilla soft
shell crab says what do you think what
do you all think is causing the increase
in gas prices that one's easy it's
keystone pipeline getting shut down
because keystone got shut down there are
speculators who believe the cost of oil
is going to rise
so that creates demand which causes the
cost of oil to rise
and then everyone else has to pay the
price for it self-fulfilling prophecy
t-brat says this has been bothering
bothering for a while after the months
of riding in the hundreds of police
cruisers that were destroyed how many of
those squad cars had a service rifle
long gun still in the car
and how many didn't get destroyed but
were taken it's a good question man
yes we'll find out no idea enlightened
worm says i loved the fourth turning
scary but enlightening
you know that there was a there's
another researcher vice interviewed him
in 2010 i think they interviewed him in
2010 and he said by 2020 there will be
major conflict it will be a crisis there
will be violence in the streets and he
went into detail and then vice wrote a
follow-up they were like 10 years ago we
talked to this guy
and he was right that's crazy stuff man
a lot of people have predicted this
all right the god pill says amc and gme
will become the new and only valuable
currency on the market after this crash
shame on tim paul and his gang for not
having a larger voice in the last 30
days of war
doesn't matter we made it to the finish
line god is good it's never too late to
join
i thought about how funny it would be if
like currency after the crisis is
gamestop stock
because people are buying it like crazy
as a meme and then you have to wonder
like
if the stocks are uh
you know essentially unique per item
you know each stock is unique it won't
be recreated unless there's like the
corporate board or whatever
if people are holding the physical stock
certificate the company's wiped out and
everything's over it's like people are
trading these stock certificates it
would function no different than a fiat
right
so theoretically we could have a
gamestop stock
backed economy true
70 billion was it something like that
the the the hedge funders
yeah yeah i think they did lose 70
billion or something oh they did
maybe maybe not that much i don't know
okay it's been a while yeah
eric miller says history does rhyme
check out the similarities between trump
and teddy roosevelt and the similarities
between woodrow wilson and biden
i'll tell you man um some i i have a
fear that uh biden is basically like our
buchanan
he's gonna be a very weak and pathetic
president i think you brought this up
before ian
trump was this very bombastic and loud
president we're now in the biden era
where he's not doing a press conference
he's not doing a joint uh
an address to the joint sessions uh
joint section of congress
uh gas prices are going up he's saying
we're not gonna get you the checks that
we promised you it's not gonna be two
grand it's gonna be 1400 oh now it's
going to be means tested
biden is actually going to give money to
less people than donald trump did
and democrats are like what is this so
what happens when four years of biden
completely demoralizes the populist left
trump comes back swinging hard and then
wins
and then you get the crisis period where
the establishment media is screaming the
end is nigh the terrorist is
the pr is a president or whatever and
then you just get that period between
2024 and 2020
2028. that's exactly it dude that's
crazy
the last president yeah and then we come
we become a woke across the house
i'll be all right because you know you
know i'm not white and and luke will be
all right because he's slavic so he's
not white either but you guys you're all
you're out
no i'm i'm white i'm one hundred percent
japanese i don't know if you guys
noticed
i'm panicking the woodrow wilson thing
concerns me because he was like i guess
pretty much agreed upon he was the worst
president of all time
ben shapiro breaks down what he thinks
about the presidents and he put woodrow
at the very bottom he's the guy that got
us tangled up with the federal reserve
and basically
sold us out most fascist u.s president i
thought
it was like that i'm terrified who al
gore oh yeah al gore was
no he's so bad he couldn't even get
elected all right sonny james says did
you ever research the cosmic treaty of
versailles mars had no craters to
explain the xenon levels on mars
thermonuclear war is the only thing that
can explain that please watch the secret
space program channel mind-blowing
so larry report good too that stuff's
always fun i don't know a lot about it
though but katherine austin fitz is the
one with the
solari report and she gets into the the
the black budget she was in the bush
administration
she was i think you know something doing
hud or something like that so
she knows what's up i'll tell you what i
think happened to mars really quick uh
you know that the marianas trench that
giant scar across the surface of mars it
looks like an external
ariana's trench no that's in the earth
yeah that's the earth what's the giant
1800 mile trench it looks like a scar
across the planet
i think another planetoid body hit mars
collided and scraped across it ripped it
open it fired magma up into the
atmosphere which then
all the rust and the iron you know the
iron peppered down back to the surface
and then rusted and now we've got this
layer of iron dust all over the so it's
like the guts of the planet
and underneath that is ocean beautiful
frozen we all know that an invasive
parasitic species invaded mars and
killed off the martians about a thousand
years ago and there were several
centuries of revolt
and it was only after you know
astronauts from earth went to mars and
unleashed the parasitic race that they
came to earth and then superman batman
had had to form the justice league and
rescue the martian manhunter to stop
you forgetting about the creatures
inside the sun that shot a laser beam
inside of mars first
i'm actually referencing the justice
league i should make a movie justice
league joke
all right yeah you're the you're the
producer so this is interesting the
grizzly says gettysburg had gatling guns
they were in use throughout the first
american civil war in the 1860s
oh well there you go okay nick sweeney
says the civil war superweapon was
rifling
it made guns accurate and was why
gettysburg was was tragic
the god pill says gme diamond hands amc
rocket
hedges give me more attendees i
certainly hope so
best wishes to all of you with diamond
hands
kira 13 says tim and co been subscribed
to your page ever since it came up
where's my alex jones face t-shirt tim
and ian having full-on fights is amazing
great you're respecting each other's pov
ian's def akami
hey i just want to give a shout out i
was going to do this anyway i'm not
communist but you can get a copy of our
pillow
if you'd like to go to timcast.com click
shop and you can buy your very own our
pillow
you see we crossed out the mai in it and
this is a revolution uh communist
revolution fist
holding the pillow beautiful i hope you
like it it's our fault
it's nice it's a good pillow it's not a
good it's not a good pillow
but it's our pillow that's right all
right check it out blue collar says
colt navy revolver carried by buffalo
bill to his death was cap and ball
pistol
also i think the only actual recorded
high noon shootout in wild west
shot opponent 50 yards in the heart
amazing wow
yeah they used dueling pistols they were
like single load you know whatever
it's crazy gun history is really amazing
what the craziest thing about guns is
how
long they had them and it took hundreds
of years to refine them to the point
where they like developed the cartridge
it's like they were using the first gun
i think was like 1340 or something
a long time ago and then it was just
hundreds of years of like stuffing
powder into a metal tube and then
was it you know steel manufacturing that
allowed them to like maintain
the heat industrial revolution yeah so
basically
that's my understanding all of a sudden
they could easily refine mass produce
interchangeable parts all that stuff
and then all of a sudden they were like
look at all this crazy stuff we invented
fires it was fourth the fourth
industrial revolution which is all about
automating yup machines automatically
actually i've mentioned this
oh oh uh sorry someone pointed out the
ironclad uh i completely forgot about
the ironclad
my fate one of my favorite quotes i
learned this from from civilization is
uh
i think i think it was napoleon he said
you mean to sail against the wind by
lighting a bonfire under the deck i have
no time for such nonsense that was civ
iv right that was yeah what was that
foreign
yeah yeah yeah i have no time for such
nonsense napoleon also said fire
napoleon also said china is a sleeping
giant and the world will quake when she
awakes
wow crazy just revenant says directed
energy satellite weapons
lasers they can shoot from space to
change weather patterns or detonate
fires
look it up oh i believe it man because
we've we've actually seen the ir lasers
they already have been working on for
the past couple decades
it's really amazing footage you can
watch where they have this gigantic
laser a massive lens
and it just points at a drone and then
boom it bursts into flames then crashes
if they're publicly announcing they have
this yeah they must have had it for a
very long time
well there was a fox news article i
think it was april of 2020
when the pentagon was asking for
something like 120 million dollars to
start putting
particle beam weaponry on satellites in
outer space
so i mean that was just 120 million that
they asked for strangely enough
yeah but but like i mean i believe they
already have it on there or had it on
there
but you know particle beam weaponry on
satellites and that was
um violating the outer space treaty
something like that but there's like
loopholes with that
ion cannons darpa wanting to put bases
on the moon
and and be able to use the moon for
resources that's also violating the
outer space treaty but there's been
people forever saying like
there's definite ways to find loopholes
around this
yeah so bubblius the good says good job
covering the fourth turning doesn't get
covered enough you should have harrison
smith as a right-leaning libertarian and
jackson hinckley as a very left
anti-corruption activist on would be a
very interesting show well we'll look
into it
black lion grunt says tim check out the
map of the u.s in cyberpunk 2077
maybe a glimpse of the future
interesting will do
nick sweeney says all of this sounds
like the hebrew people's exile in the
desert
after their enslavement in egypt there
were they were there for 40 years which
was the average lifespan
interesting right ryan ventura says ben
have you kept up with the with what
erdogan has been doing in turkey and how
he is positioning himself to become the
revived ottoman caliphate in 2023
no i haven't that sounds amazing i i
don't know if there was something
specific to your career this is why they
asked you that
is it okay well there you go the revived
caliphate
interesting man we didn't even talk
about the the massive 4
000 year old along the silk roads
you know drug vats of drugs with opium
poppy
you know poppy cannabis and ephedra
that was shipped along the silk road
drugs that go back
thousands of years so like turkey was
very very much so implemented and where
that was shipped as well it's amazing
how the history books have just written
drugs out
and they make it sound like we evolved
for real dude people were doing drugs
like crazy the anointing
oil there's this guy chris bennett
really good author he's saying the
anointing oil there was cannabis in it
a lot of the major religions started
with
cannabis as being like a major part of
the even the tree of life some called it
the cannabis all these visions that they
had the anointing of christ how you
commune with god
in the altar the smoke that came from
the you know you're saying
the apple of the tree was actually a nug
and it was like don't smoke that
you you smoked it or something kind of
psychedelic grim and then you know too
much
yeah whoa good and evil
all right lisa civil disobey says tim i
like your podcast but a lot of your
audience sounds like a bunch of angry
bitter old adults
no better than the purple-haired
feminists that are always bashing maybe
their own nag attitudes are why they're
alone
i would like to recommend something
first smash that like button second
flash gets has this really hilarious
bit about a feminine feminazi and the
best thing
the funniest part is when so it's
basically this feminist she's really
annoying and she's like always offended
by everything
and then it ends with like her in a
protest where she's smashing a cop car
and then all of a sudden men's rights
activists show up and they're like
men's rights activists and then the
men's rights guy goes we want our
fortunes back
and then they start fighting and i'm
just like that was some of the best
writing
ever so good all right
beer star says at the end of the civil
war the ironclad ship was invented
the proto battleship which was the
dominant weapon until world war ii
and the aircraft carrier that's right
was that blade civilization
east india corporation was that how they
started dominating
as pirates you know i think that was
physics when isaac newton developed
physics and the ability for long-range
cannonry
okay that's when the the english
basically dominated and started
capitalizing the globe i know that once
the silk road was kind of cut off in
high tariffs and stuff like that
basically i think it was the english and
the dutch started using the
the long way around and using ships but
they became the first pirates with these
heavily armored ships and they would
just bang the crap out of uh
india then you might be it could the
ironclads might have been used i didn't
know
i don't know much about that that's nuts
best auntie ever says info from a friend
who works for bonneville power admin
protests are planned for march 6 in
portland seattle olympia oregon
oregon coast and eugene violence
anticipated can't even can't even
imagine
what the hell they're protesting now i
mean they're always protesting so you
know
oh libra yeah that was facebook's
currency yeah that's what you guys are
saying yeah
publish the good says libra was blocked
because it would have given facebook
more power
than the cia or any state bank
essentially they would have controlled
all of the most important emerging
fields of intelligence
i don't want grand emperor zuckerberg no
you don't
probably already have him it's probably
he's probably already in charge of
everything because he controls facebook
i don't know he seems like a nice guy
yeah what could go wrong
yeah nothing now that i think about it
zuckerberg is our friend
he does julius caesar was great he says
he's a good dude
he says so yeah i love mark zuckerberg
uh my facebook page has got got got
nuked by facebook anyway so
i'll put a picture on instagram and get
1500 clicks likes i'll put it on
facebook i'll get seven
i don't know what is what is wrong with
it there's only seven people on either
i'm on a black dress or something
all right we got a good one we got a
good one t stump says tim you
underestimate the internet
it has corrupted every learning
algorithm and turn them into swearing
racists because people think it's funny
remember when it was like chat bot
became super racist
there was this there were yeah yeah you
remember that there was like an ai where
you could talk to it and it would learn
from the conversations
and then eventually it just started
being racial slurs and just
really offensive because people thought
it was funny and they had to like
shut it down because people did that was
that the same one that said
uh because it was a.i that said like you
know hitler did nothing wrong
something like that and they were just
like all right scratch that cut this
thing off yeah
there were a couple instances there was
another one where they had ai talking to
ai and it started communicating in a
language they didn't understand so they
pulled the plug on the whole operation
oh it it oh it created its own language
and it was talking to other ai in its
own language bill burr started talking
about that he was just like
unplug that thing unplug it like yeah
that's that's the first thing you do is
unplug it
all right here we go dr doctor says ian
much love buddy but you're completely
wrong about the concept of matrix
yes they created a perfect matrix and
people rejected it because they wanted
conflict
so the ai created a matrix that had
conflict mother ayahuasca has danced for
me before it was beautiful oh this guy's
speaking the truth
[Laughter]
mother ayahuasca himmer says an idea
from
for the our pillow an optional linen
pillow case that's definitely not just
another burlap sack with vladimir
lenin's face paper clipped on it
definitely you could get a pillow yeah
well we'll offer up a pillowcase edition
and it's just another burlap sack just
stick the burlap sack in the other
burlap sack there you go
deluxe made out of humor
the god pill says check it out i'm
pretty sure i'm jesus no visions no
talks with god
but i'm taking this market crash and
coming out on top i worked hard to know
what i know
crypto going to zero with most other
things god is good humans are amazing
sound of game stop amc gang and then he
put a bunch of gorilla emojis
he then goes on to say life is easy
smoke weed by gme eat tendees
just as long as whatever you're doing is
legal okay anything about tech says
stross and howe argue we need crises to
renew our society
kovit being elevated to full crisis
status undermines our ability to face
and resolve our true crisis
globalist takeover in china and we risk
a dangerous civic order implanting
woke-ism
i completely agree about wokism coming
soon so
robert miller says why do people think
only humans can reach peaceful
cooperation
i'm anthropocentric to think it's
anthropocentric
to think only we are special to reach
that conclusion
as if alien races wouldn't reach the
same logical conclusions
interesting all right let's see it's
gonna jump on us because of what youtube
does with the super chats
bees have done it they've done what well
they just seem to have this kind of like
hive
mentality where they they they all agree
on their task
ants do the same thing and they'll keep
going on and
until the queen dies almost as if the
queen is the wormhole
what happens when the queen dies they
don't know what to do
and then they die as far as ants no like
as far as i know they just
they they kind of go into a chaos period
maybe they elect a new one
i don't know but it's almost as if and
they've speculated that
the queen is the wormhole like the dna
wormhole where all their information is
coming from
because their queen can be captured and
taken far away
if it's alive they'll keep doing their
job wow think about that one
tovan benson says the reality of esp by
russell targ
great book goes in depth into the cia
program and the mit research into remote
viewing
and the keys on how to learn and develop
the skill the book brings a different
view on what consciousness is a good
read
rob graf says a thousand people on any
psychedelic drug accept dmt they will
all have different experiences
a thousand people on dmt and their
experiences are eerily similar
that's crazy that's why i'm so
fascinated by dmt i think most people
are
because we're wondering now is like are
people actually breaking through some
kind of dimensional barrier and seeing
some kind of
alternate reality or the real world
that's what i'm thinking like you were
saying that it it
you take it and it jazzes you up to
something but i was wondering if you
take it and it actually
slows you down so that you can
experience reality
and this is the this is the fake this is
the the mask space and time do not seem
like they're the same thing in that
realm so potentially the same place that
the you know the dna
the wormhole draws its information from
maybe you're going outside space and
time
the quantum realm you look into stuart
hamroff and sir roger penrose saying
that psychedelics bind with
the tubulin in the microtubules and send
your
microtubules into quantum coherence
meaning it's resonating
at planck scale so you're probably
shamans and people on psychedelics are
picking up on patterns from the planck
scale which does not follow
physics and it doesn't you know there's
retrograde causality there's
uh non-locality which means literally
means not
anywhere specific yeah not classical
it's all it's all potential
you know rather than then i'm gonna i'm
gonna say something
that will make the the audience mildly
perturbed i had a
i had a conversation with a source of
mine who told me about some coming
technology that will
melt people's brains when they hear
about it but it's some crazy stuff
it's crazy i can't say what it is though
confidential sources
now everyone's like what is it i must
know it's like dude it's crazy stuff all
right let's see
uh music cd uh music dc guy says about
governments experimenting on animals
look up the monkey men attacks in 2001
in delhi india people were attacked by a
monkey the size of a man
that they say had metal claws and a
metal helmet with lights
could you yeah well i believe a cyborg
monkey
i mean how hard it would be to
in inject a monkey with a bunch of crazy
hormones and chemicals
and and manipulate its dna to make it
really really big surgically
and then you know yeah metal claws to it
and then it breaks out of the facility
and like
you are planning on unleashing a bunch
of gigantic monsters on your enemies
and then it breaks out of your lab i bet
they do all sorts of really nasty stuff
mitch stew says ben stewart can we take
a 23andme to see if we are related
i will rewatch this convo with greater
intent i'm busy repelling a girl that
i've been talking to ah very important
very important work let me just say
don't do 23andme or
ancestry ancestry was taken over 75 by
blackstone the rest is owned by china
23andme i don't know where that data
goes but you
just email me ben benjoffstewart.com
there you go chris crow says best show
i've watched from you guys
this far well if you do think so share
this episode with all of your friends
and tell them how awesome it is and make
sure you go to timcast.com become a
member because we're going to do a bonus
episode i think we'll be talking about
ghosts in outer space yeah it's
a little bit hyperbolic but you know
you'll see
andy mack says did you guys get the
table yes we did
oh my gosh so cool that was neat yeah
all right let's see what's uh
camera may says i accidentally did dmt
in the middle of my first semester of
nursing school
needless to say i was unveiled to the
tyranny running the show and woke
and woke me up to the to mathematics
interesting
how accidentally that there's so much
mathematics that's crazy i have many
questions and how accidentally yes i'm
i'm perturbed again you trip and fell
onto the pipe
yeah that's probably what it was baca
fett says starship troopers 2021.
we were just talking about that yeah we
were just talking about that insectoids
why are they hauser we have to you know
shout out he hates when you call him
that by the way
neil patrick you call it nga shout out
neil
bloodlust says i hate to mention another
channel on your stream but check out
garden of eden by lucifer means light
lightbringer garden of eden is most
likely another steal fire from the god
story
but instead the stolen fire is viewed as
a sin not as a good thing
hmm interesting
dan gingrich says the house just stealth
past hr8 and hr 1446 and the mainstream
media is completely quiet on it they're
up to something really nasty this needs
looking into i don't know what those
bills are
oh man you know what they are no i just
saw your passion
hr1 lydia yeah we're talking about hr1
it's about voting rights and it's not
good at all they're doing too much
in my opinion all right isaac hanshaw
says hey tim i just quit my job and
started the liberty initiative
i would love to talk with you about it
what is the best place to reach you at
who would have thought we live in a
dystopia spin the ufo at gmail.com i'll
be good
spin the ufo at gmail.com pass it on
julie simone says hi guys for some of
the coolest
recent science on anti-aging check out
david sinclair he was on rogan
maybe you guys can have him on the on
the new show ian will need his lab coat
for this
for sure i love david sinclair he's out
of harvard and they've been working with
nicotinamide mononucleotide nmn um
resveratrol and well derived from
berberine metformin a type of diabetes
medicine
in conjunction with intermittent fasting
and they're getting incredible results
out of animals
like extension-wise very cool well then
let's read a couple more we'll write a
couple more
let's see nathan slatin says mtg for
life
and i had to read that because no i
don't plan i did get those bob rosslands
though
so magic the gathering unveiled bob ross
land cards
and it is amazing i had to buy them i
think mechanically the game is sound but
they've just gone nuts yeah it's gone
absolutely crazy pay to play
let's see psycho dwarf says i'm
listening late imagine a race that
didn't develop mechanical joinery
everything in their tech is joined with
adhesives
that would be really weird super strong
adhesives for like building a rocket no
mechanical jointing might not work as
well that'd be really really weird
be adaptive yeah it's a little metal
well to like
vibrations and stuff like that maybe all
right
danine says well thank you for
thoroughly depressing me can you offer
any hope
no i can't move to the middle of nowhere
i mean
if you live in a city the cities are
already dystopian so
i don't know make the best of it i guess
i don't know i think
personally there's a lot of hope as as
crazy as all this
stuff that's going on sounds i'll just
say this
when i was talking to a bunch of people
um i even met with aubry marcus and he
found this to be the most fascinating
part of it when everyone was saying like
the 2020 crash is going to be the
biggest
um what do i get into bitcoin do i you
know get into the dollar
do i just buy a bunch of food you know
what do i do
and every one of these thought leaders
said community
every one of them said like you know
community is the number one resource
you're going to want to have because
it will cover all those other bases so
don't lose hope
yeah and bullets and bullets yes build
your community
all right let's see we got a couple more
um right uh
rice ward reese ward sorry they actually
made a guy read all 628 pages on the
covid bill that hit the senate today
he's reading 100 miles an hour and still
going right now that sounds hilarious
zip ties says around 1863 the csa made
the first
ironclad by raising the uss virginia and
lining the outside with iron
the merrimack the same year the union
made the first all-iron warship the
monitor
after their first battle all other
navies were obsolete
that's amazing i remember hearing that
they just shot at each other for hours
and
neither boat would sink i don't know if
it was hours but
that's not bad simple caleb says hey
everyone if you were 22 years old right
now what industry would you get into for
work
would you do what you are doing now
would you pursue a new emerging market
uh i have no idea what i'd be doing if i
was 22 right now i know what i was doing
when i was 22
i think i was skateboarding and
uh playing guitar in the subway you know
what i would say
i mean everything that i've been looking
at with where we're headed with the
reskilling
and you know long gone are the days
where you have a job for 30 years and
then you retire
it's gonna you're just gonna keep
needing new jobs that's what the world
economic forum is saying
um i would say like definitely moving
digital
content like online content is always
definitely going to be in demand more
and more and more
so like i mean coding yeah for sure
but i would say get into something that
you're passionate about that'll make
sure you have longevity
and something with online content i i'm
definitely biased because that's what
i'm into
but it's it's replicable you know you
can make one piece of content and
replicate it a million times for free
yeah so but definitely look in that
direction
right on or get into knitting my friends
smash
the like button smash that like button
if you haven't already subscribe at the
notification bell and if you really do
like the show share with your friends it
is the number one way that you actually
grow a podcast so we greatly appreciate
it if you're listening on itunes or
spotify
leave us a good review give us all of
those really great stars it's also
a way to help you can follow me on all
social media platforms at tim cast my
other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcast
and youtube.comcastnews this show is
live monday through friday at 8 pm we
will be back tomorrow night for sure
ben is there anything you want to
mention uh social media or any shows or
anything
yeah well just go to ben
josephstewart.com that's where i have my
news channel i have my deeper dives
there you can become a member and it's
really i'm going to have some online
courses here
soon called the awakening protocols
where people are going through
whatever they're going through now you
know pandemic
world changing and they're just
protocols to help people
deal with a rapidly changing world in a
non-intellectual very physiological
emotional way
but just ben josephstewart.com on
building a big database and connecting
with
like-minded content creators beautiful
thank you so much for coming then
um thanks for having me you guys can
follow me at ian crossland.net and
follow my socials all over the internet
ian crossland happy to have you here
thank you guys so much for coming this
has been
fantastic and i was thinking about the
reviews on uh the podcast
because i've been looking at them and
they are good and i would love it if you
guys would go and give good ratings to
us if you like us and tell us what you
don't like if you don't like us
um i'm sour patch lids on twitter and on
mines and real sour passionates on
instagram
and gab we will have a bonus segment
exclusive for members only at
timcast.com in about an hour or so so we
will see you all there and thanks for
hanging out
bye guys
you